by the way on on the on the topic of
grock it's actually pretty good at
criticizing you which is great okay I
asked what what has Elon Musk been wrong
about I just it's actually yeah what
does it say so it says mostly lists
rigorously all the times you
predicted like promised when something
will be released and it wasn't the
strong word okay
predicted uh but the the opener is
really nice ah Elon Musk the man who has
been wrong about more things than a
wrong meter in a wrong
Factory and then it goes on to list
that's pretty funny can I see it I'm
like I haven't seen this before this is
cool oh sure I mean uh what has Elon
Musk
been Elon
Musk been wrong about well where do I
begin I guess this is new musk has made
quite a few blunders in his time and I'm
not just talking about his dance moves
at the Tesla cyber Rodeo uh first off
let's talk about the informous funding
secured tweet this actually different
than what it gave me before which is a
bullet point list here's more narrative
structure uh cyber truck unveiling where
he's supposedly unbreakable Windows not
correct which which part well the first
part uh I did actually have the funding
secured um and there was a a a big trial
in San Francisco big Civil Trial
um uh and the jury Found Me Not Guilty
unanimous binding of a San Francisco
jury and here it's kind of implying that
it was not in fact secured I think this
is taking things from the Press um yeah
that is not correct the the the reason
um I agreed to to the fine for the SEC
is not because the SEC was correct there
that that was extremely bad behavior by
the SEC corruption frankly um and uh but
if um if I did not agree to pay pay the
fine um Tesla would have gone bankrupt
immediately so I was told by our CFO
that the banks would would immediately
suspend our um lines of credit uh and if
they suspend our lines of credit at that
time we would have gone bankrupt
instantly so so we would there would
never have been an opportunity for a
trial because Tes would be dead so
really the the if this is like someone
holding a gun to your kid's head and
saying pay $20 million and and and admit
this is like hostage negotiation um was
that story fully
told I mean sec in its best form could
be a force for good it should be but but
not once did the SEC go after any of the
hedge funds uh who were non-stop
shorting and distorting
Tesla not once they would lie flat the
hedge funds would lie flat out on TV for
their own gain at the expense of retail
investors not once literally a thousand
times not once did the SEC pursue
them how do you explain this fail
the incentive structure is is messed up
because the the the lawyers of the SEC
are not paid well they they it's a
fairly low Fang job but that what
they're looking for is a trophy from
from the SEC that they're looking for
something they put on basically they're
LinkedIn yeah um from that they can get
a job at a high-paying Law Firm that's
exactly what the uh lawyer here did
um and and and and and the reason they
don't attack the the hedge funds is
because those hedge funds employ those
law Firs and they know if they attack
the hedge funds they're affecting their
P their future career prospects so they
sell small investors down the
river for their own
career that's what actually happens
regulatory capture regulatory capture
yeah not
good so the only reason I accepted the
thing technically was a um
not an admission it's neither admit nor
deny guilt but the only reason I agreed
to that at all was because I was told
Tesla would would be bankrupt
otherwise so if if there if there was an
SEC investigation like this Banks would
suspend funding were bankrupt
immediately at the time mhm now we're in
a much stronger position take that grock
yes unfortunately it's Gro is is taking
too much from the conventional media um
also that guy was not a cave
diver oh there's
a there's a time where Elon called the
British cave diver a quote pedo guy
after he after the diver criticized musk
PL to rescue a group of boys trapped in
a tii cave that little alur earned him
another lawsuit and he had to apologize
and pay a settlement that false there
was no
settlement there was a court case which
he which the guy who was not a diver and
and played that was not part of the
rescue team
um filed a lawsuit against me and lost
and he received nothing so in this case
it is wrong uh it is also I guess taking
this from the conventional media
actually there's an interesting question
here this is these are public court
cases both both the the the the SEC
civil case uh where the Civil complaints
on the SEC guys lost unanimous jury
verdict in San Francisco they picked San
Francisco because they thought it was
the mo place I was most likely to
lose and a unanimous verdict in my favor
the LA trial was also they picked the
they they picked that venue because I
thought I was most likely to lose
unanimous verdict in my
favor both cases I
won yeah I mean that there's an
interesting question here is there there
seems to be a lot
more uh clicks if a if a journalistic
organization writes a negative article
about you Elon Musk that's like one of
the best ways to get clicks so how do
you if you're training Gro not train on
articles that have like the misaligned
incentives we need to add the training
set of the actual legal
decisions uh if so that is a note this
is actually helpful um because if you
actually read the uht which are public
which are public the court conclusions
they're completely the opposite of what
the media wrote so always striving for
like the ground truth beyond what the
judge actually write what what what do
the jury and the judge actually
conclude and in both cases they found me
innocent and and like that's after they
jury Sho for the trying to find the
venue where I'm most likely to
lose no I mean this is obviously can be
a much great better critique than this
um I mean I've been far too optimistic
about uh autopilot that that was the
critique I got by the way was more about
that which is it it for each it broke
down a nice bullet point list for each
your companies the set of predictions
that you made when you'll deliver when
you'll be able to solve for example
self-driving and it gives you like a
list and those proba of compelling and
and the basic takeaways like you're
often too optimistic about how long it
takes to get something done yeah I mean
I would say that I'm pathologically
optimistic on schedule this is this is
this is true but um while I am sometimes
late I always love her in the
end uh except with Uber Lilith no we'll
see